В ефірі «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом
та Ханною Ціммерман.
Усім доброго вечора.
Нова холодна війна триває не тільки
на землі, а й у космосі.
Один із найуспішніших
наукових проєктів людства
- за крок до провалу.
Міжнародна космічна станція (МКС) -
це щось набагато більше
за космічну станцію, чи то сяйво
в небі, яке іноді можна побачити.
Наперекір і, можливо,
навіть завдяки всім
невдачам і труднощам,
така станція -
це інтернаціональний символ.
На форпості у космосі залучено
16 держав,
5 космічних організацій, NASA і
«Роскосмос».
Однак нині новопризначений голова
«Роскосмосу» Юрій Борисов
заявив, що Росія вийде
з проєкту МКС після 2024 року.
І побудує власну космічну станцію.
Космос завжди був частиною
політики, але важливіше,
що це символ миру на орбіті.
Тож, яке майбутнє чекає
на МКС - поки невідомо.
Детальніше про події -
Лара Відекінг та Сімон Грубеш.
Листопад, 1998 рік.
Перша частина конструкції МКС
вирушає з російською
ракетою у космос.
Через два роки перший
екіпаж космічної станції складається
з одного американського астронавта
та двох російських космонавтів.
Вони працюють пліч-о-пліч,
об'єднавши свої сили.
Живуть разом.
Досліджують разом.
Після років конкуренції за космос,
МКС стала осередком співпраці.
Але ніщо не триває вічно.
«Ми виконаємо свої зобов'язання
перед нашими партнерами щодо МКС», -
заявив голова «Роскосмосу» Борисов.
Рішення схвалено:
ми вийдемо з проєкту МКС
після 2024 року.
Я думаю, до того часу
ми почнемо будувати
російську орбітальну станцію.
Саме так виглядатиме нова російська
орбітальна службова станція.
Крім того, росіяни заявляють,
що вони хотіли б
відключити свою частину МКС і
керувати нею самостійно.
Росія, серед іншого,
забезпечує корекцію орбіти,
тобто підіймає космічну станцію
знову і знову
за допомогою
свого космічного апарата.
Натомість американська сторона,
тобто Захід, забезпечує
зв'язок та електрику.
Розділити ці дві функції
буде дуже важко.
Не минуло навіть п'яти днів
з моменту співпраці на МКС
росіянина і європейки:
Олега Артем'єва і Саманти Крістофоретті.
Міжнародну командну роботу
у минулому високо оцінив Путін:
Ми раді, що наші фахівці
успішно працюють
у межах програми МКС
із колегами зі Сполучених Штатів,
однією із провідних космічних націй.
Це видовищний приклад того,
як ефективне партнерство
двох наших країн
діє на благо всього людства.
Досі МКС знаходилася поза
політичними дискусіями.
Національність чи кордони тут
не мали значення.
До сьогодні.
Тепер чітко зрозуміло одне:
Переломний момент
вплинув і на космос.
Німецький астронавт
Рейнхольд Евальд сам був у космосі
на російській
космічній станції «Мир».
Зараз він професор
в Інституті космічних систем.
У прямому ефірі зі Штутгарта.
Пане Евальде, добрий вечір.
Доброго вечора, пане Зіверсе.
Як Ви сприйняли сьогоднішні новини?
О, будь ласка, не треба.
Це відчуження партнерства
з політичних цілей,
яке ми створювали з МКС
протягом багатьох років.
Станція на це не заслуговує.
МКС створена не для цього
і це не повинно затьмарювати
досягнення
Міжнародної космічної станції.
До цього випадку вважалося,
що політичні проблеми
залишаються на землі.
Національність - не проблема на МКС.
А який у Вас досвід щодо цього?
Вид на Землю не вказує меж.
І саме ця міжнародна співпраця, яка
підтримує одне одного,
досягаючи спільного успіху,
враховуючи великі завдання,
характеризує цю співпрацю
на космічній станції.
Ось чому це називають партнерством.
Тобто виходить, що не має значення,
хто ти: росіянин, американець
чи німець за національністю?
Так, це не має значення,
адже кожен привносить
індивідуальний багаж знань
та має різні навчальні процеси.
Але з цих складових
утворюється спільна мета.
Ми б не хотіли обходитися
без російського досвіду,
та підтримки
наземного центру управління.
Зважаючи на останні події,
можна було спостерігати,
як російські космонавти,
вивісили свій прапор,
наприклад, на МКС.
Те саме вони зробили на
самопроголошених народних республіках,
що на сході України,
зі словами: «Ми святкуємо досягнення
Росії військових цілей у космосі».
Як Ви це прокоментуєте?
Це болить, це дуже болить через
мою довгострокову співпрацю
з російськими колегами.
І я не хочу навіть уявляти,
який тиск застосовувався.
У будь-якому випадку
це не сприяє співпраці.
Тут діє правило
«не питай, не відповідай».
Я маю на увазі, що
у космосі вистачає роботи
і без обговорення політики.
Саме так вважатимуть колеги
із західного сегмента.
Пане Евальде, поговорімо
про технічні наслідки.
Чи впаде МКС, якщо Росія її покине?
Ні, це орбітально-технічно
неможливо.
І все ж партнери першими
домовились про вихід до 2024 року.
Є, звичайно, партнерство з
Європейською космічною агенцією,
а також із NASA, котрі кажуть,
мовляв,
ми хочемо піти до 2030 року.
Росія просто перша ухвалила рішення.
Проте ми ще не дожили до 2024 року.
У нас ще є час, аби
ґрунтовно розглянути
всі «за» та «проти».
перш ніж зробити такий крок.
Тобто Ви припускаєте, що
Росія може знову дати задніх?
Або ж це був просто блеф,
пропаганда у найширшому сенсі,
і врешті-решт нічого не зміниться?
Зі щоденної співпраці нам відомо,
що росіяни теж достатньо
виграють завдяки західному сегменту
та інших партнерів.
Незалежно від того,
чи це передача даних,
чи постачання електричної енергії,
усім цим доведеться займатися, якщо
ізолювати станцію
як російську космічну станцію,
перезапустити її з 24.
Тож я ставлюся
до цього дуже скептично.
Чи було б можливо,
щоб МКС функціонувала тільки
за підтримки Заходу?
Так, але це був би найгірший варіант.
Якщо б ми побачили,
що система виходить з ладу,
було б добре
мати резервну систему.
У випадку з
американським космічним шатлом,
це була ракета «Союз», яка потім
привезла людей на космічну станцію.
Звичайно, цього б більше не було.
Це означає, що ми програємо.
Ми просто втрачаємо другу опору.
На сьогодні
Росія висловила бажання
побудувати власну космічну станцію.
Наскільки це реалістично,
на Вашу думку?
Частини російської космічної станції вже
були доставлені на космічну станцію.
Щоправда, із серйозними затримками,
навіть складнощами, я б сказав.
До речі, остання частина була
науковим модулем кілька місяців тому.
Якщо у 2024 все це стане
марнотратством,
то Росія зазнає значних
інвестиційних втрат.
Оцінка німецького астронавта
Рейнхольда Евальда.
Пане Евальде, щиро дякуємо
Вам за розмову.
З радістю, сподіваємось
на кращі часи.
Неодмінно.
Розмову було записано
через технічні причини.
Повертаємося до земних проблем:
Війна Росії проти України
усе ще триває, -
це стало центральною темою
обговорення сьогодні в Брюсселі.
Європа шукає вихід з дефіциту газу.
Спільний.
Нелегко, адже Європейський Союз
функціонує як асоціація,
уякій багато людей думають
передусім про себе,
поки не стає справді спекотно.
Тож кожен, хто очікує від екстреного
плану чітких інструкцій,
де кожна країна виконуватиме
своє завдання, буде розчарованим.
Ухвалений сьогодні план
економії газу в Європі
у дусі ЄС: нав'язані компроміси
та положення з винятків.
Більше про події з Брюсселя -
Флоріан Нойган.
Вид з його кабінету прямісінько
на Ейфелеву вежу в Парижі
не може не захоплювати.
А погляд Фатіха Біроля,
який дає інтерв'ю для ZDF -
кардинально інший.
Питання до турецького економіста та
експерта з енергетики просте:
«Чи готова Європа до наступної зими?»
Абсолютно ні,
ми відстаємо від графіка.
Якщо ми не вживемо
жодних серйозних заходів, то
цілком можливий
дефіцит газопостачання.
На мою думку, ця зима стане
справжнім історичним
випробуванням для Європи.
Це випробування, у якому вони
мають пройти сьогодні перший етап.
Особлива зустріч міністрів енергетики
ЄС в Брюсселі:
Хто скільки зекономить, хто готовий
ділитися своїм газом з іншими?
Зустріч, від якої
очікувалася гостра дискусія.
Насправді все було навпаки.
Сьогодні ми посилаємо
потужний сигнал.
Не тільки до Володимира Путіна,
якому вкотре
не вдалося розколоти Євросоюз.
Особливо в енергетичній
та кліматичній сфері
за останні тижні та місяці
Європа досягла великої,
я б сказав, дивовижної єдності,
і сьогодні ми це бачимо.
Про що ж сьогодні
домовилися країни ЄС:
Щоб контролювали споживання газу,
з серпня по березень його використання
зменшать на 15 %.
Звучить добре, але це можливо лише
завдяки численним виняткам.
Наприклад, для острівних держав.
Або для країн, котрі,
нібито чи насправді,
мають занадто мало
газових сполучень з іншими.
А також для цілих
галузей промисловості.
І що важливо:
скорочення на волонтерських засадах.
Це план, який багатьох
присутніх у Брюсселі,
чи то в інших містах,
змушує задуматись:
Чи буде цього достатньо?
Ймовірно, 15% недостатньо
з огляду на те, як Росія зараз надалі зменшує
обсяги постачання газу
через газогін «Північний потік-1».
Але це краще, ніж нічого.
На наш погляд, навіть за найсприятливіших умов
Європа муситиме скоротити
споживання газу на 20%,
щоб узимку запобігти проблемному становищу.
Та насправді надзвичайний план містить мало вказівок
про те, як саме країни ЄС мають заощаджувати газ.
Наприкінці дня міністр економіки Словаччини
висловив сумніви щодо того,
чи дійсно цей план, розроблений країнами ЄС,
може змусити населення заощаджувати газ.
Споживачі економлять газ і будуть це робити тому,
що ціна на нього зросте вдесятеро,
а не тому, що так каже ЄС.
Європа готується до кризової зими.
І багато хто очікує,
що незабаром тут знову доведеться зустрітися,
якщо не вдасться досягнути
власних цілей із заощадження газу.
Ось який вигляд має сьогодні європейська солідарність:
Іспанія, наприклад, підтримує
компроміс, якого досягла ЄС.
Міністерка енергетики Іспанії вважає,
що інші країни не можуть платити
за політичні помилки Німеччини.
Тож платити за ці помилки
доведеться передусім нам самим,
і Німеччина, ймовірно, муситиме
заощаджувати значно більше газу,
ніж інші країни.
Звичайно, великі промислові підприємства
не можуть просто сидіти склавши руки
й сподіватися, що все йтиме як по маслу.
Вони мають розробляти план «Б» -
власний план заощадження.
Петер Кунц продемонструє це на прикладі
другої за величиною сталеливарної компанії
в Німеччині, розташованої в Зальцгіттері.
Європейська економіка в умовах війни -
до неї адаптується німецька промисловість.
Сталеливарне підприємство «Salzgitter AG»
не зможе працювати зовсім без газу,
але з обмеженою кількістю енергоносія - цілком.
Наразі я не можу стверджувати,
чи зможемо ми так заощадити 15%.
На деяких нагрівних печах, наприклад,
ми вимкнули пристрої попереднього підігріву.
Тепер попереднє нагрівання триває дещо довше,
але ми компенсуємо це більшою кількістю працівників.
Та воно того варте, зважаючи на теперішні
високі ціни на енергоносії.
Дорогий газ автоматично більше заощаджують,
це використовують політики для своїх закликів.
На своєму металургійному комбінаті
компанія «Salzgitter AG» намагається
виробляти енергію у своїх модернізованих системах,
які раніше були електростанцією.
Встановлюючи вітрогенератори на власній території,
компанія сприймає кризу як можливість для розвитку.
Так концерн готується
до цієї суворої зими й тих, що ще попереду.
Десять днів тому
ми ухвалили рішення про інвестиції,
відповідно до якого плануємо замінити одну з домен
на цьому виробництві у Зальцгіттері
на нову технологію, яка на перехідному етапі
використовуватиме природний газ,
а в перспективі - водень.
Можливо, ця газова криза також допоможе
пришвидшити розвиток водневих технологій,
а отже, ще швидше здійснити перехід.
Що менше залежності від газу, то менше викидів CO2.
Компанія прагне застосувати водень
для екологічного виробництва сталі.
Експериментальна установка
вже розміщена в Зальцгіттері.
Коли ми збільшимо масштаби цієї установки,
то отримаємо споруду,
висота якої становитиме понад 130 м.
Це будуть вежі, які нагадуватимуть хмарочоси,
в яких з заліза вилучатимуть оксид.
У довгостроковій перспективі
вони мають замінити домни.
У такому майбутньому є лише одна каверза:
«Salzgitter» планує здійснити перехід,
використовуючи водневу суміш.
Для цього підприємству потрібно
навіть більше природного газу, ніж сьогодні.
По-перше, нам буде потрібен газ лише з 2025 року.
Не думаю, що тоді ми переживатимемо
газову кризу в таких масштабах,
як сьогодні.
З іншого боку, як вважає керівник одного
з найбільших виробників сталі в Європі,
Німеччина не має допустити, щоб країну паралізувало﻿
від занадто великих побоювань через цю кризу.
А чи не боїться, власне, керівник, що його підприємству
припинять газопостачання?
По-перше, ми забезпечуємо місто Зальцгіттер
центральним опаленням.
Це, звісно, можливо лише тоді,
коли працює виробництво.
По-друге, ми третій за величиною
постачальник питної води
у федеральній землі Нижня Саксонія.
І по-третє, тут ми виробляємо лінії з'єднання
для підключення терміналів зрідженого газу
у Вільгельмсгафені та Брунсбюттелі.
Це означає, що енергетичний перехід можливий,
лише якщо в нас є сталь,
отже, якщо наше виробництво працює.
Без сталевих труб із Зальцгіттера буде неможливо
під'єднати термінали зрідженого газу
і швидко здобути енергетичну незалежність.
Такою є економіка в умовах газової війни,
і вона досить складна.
Про поточну ситуацію в Україні розповість Ханна.
Сьогодні надійшло повідомлення про те,
що Україна отримала наступну партію
важкої зброї з Німеччини:
обіцяні реактивні системи
залпового вогню типу Mars II
вже доставлені в зону бойових дій,
а разом з ними - ще одна партія
САУ Panzerhaubitze 2000.
Тим часом Росія здійснила масований обстріл
південного узбережжя України.
На морському курорті Затока
було зруйновано багато будинків.
Обстрілу зазнали також південні райони Миколаївщини.
Стало відомо, що з наступного року
розмір виплат для покупців електромобілів зменшиться.
Так, за повідомленнями ЗМІ, за транспортні засоби,
які коштують менш як 40 тис. євро,
замість 6000 євро покупці отримуватимуть 4500.
За дорожчі електромобілі до 65 тис. євро
передбачені виплати у розмірі 3000 євро.
До кінця цього року також повністю скасують
виплати за плагін-гібридні автомобілі.
Завтра уряд має ухвалити відповідне рішення.
Сьогодні Конституційний суд Німеччини
розглядав справу щодо Фонду
відновлення після COVID-19,
що становить 750 млрд євро.
Ці кошти мають допомогти відновити
економіку держав-членів ЄС
після пандемії коронавірусу.
Передбачається, що для цього вони спільно
виплачуватимуть борги.
Саме це позивачі вважають неприпустимим.
Вони вбачають у цьому рішенні
непередбачувані економічні ризики
для державного бюджету Німеччини.
Розгляд справи продовжать завтра.
Суд ухвалить рішення щонайменше за кілька місяців.
За 13 місяців після фатального нападу з ножем
на перехожих у місті Вюрцбург
компетентний земельний суд постановив
передати підсудного на невизначений термін
у психіатричну лікарню.
Суд вважає доведеним,
що 32-річний чоловік був неосудним
на момент вчинення злочину.
Висновки двох експертів підтвердили,
що він хворий на параноїдальну шизофренію.
У червні 2021 року в універмазі біженець із Сомалі
вбив кухонним ножем трьох незнайомих жінок.
Ще кілька людей отримали поранення.
Полум'я не знає меж.
Полум'я не зупиняється
навіть перед заповідниками,
які потребують особливого захисту.
Пожежні служби борються з вогнем,
та не можуть взяти ситуацію під контроль.
З національного парку «Чеська Швейцарія» в Чехії,
де вже кілька днів тривають інтенсивні лісові пожежі,
вогонь перекинувся на територію
Національного парку «Саксонська Швейцарія».
Ситуація дуже складна,
як і в Бранденбурзі, де площа, охоплена вогнем,
становить майже 1200 футбольних полів.
Наслідки кліматичної кризи, зокрема жахливої спеки
із надзвичайно сильною засухою
цього літа відчутні для кожного
навіть там, куди ми спеціально їздимо,
щоб милуватися і насолоджуватися
нібито недоторканою природою.
Там, де має бути крига,
і де всі зараз роблять багато фото,
щоб згодом навіть найменші могли зрозуміти,
як усе виглядало раніше.
Штефан Ляйферт побував в Альпах.
Там, де сьогодні приземлився гвинтокрил,
100 років тому був льодовик.
Взявши з собою 50 кг вимірювальних приладів,
ми супроводжуємо географів з Айхштета
на льодовик Ґепачфернер,
розташований високо в Ецтальських Альпах.
Ґепачфернер
тане зі швидкістю понад 100 метрів на рік
в особливо теплі роки.
Він тане найшвидше
серед усіх альпійських льодовиків.
Щороку сюди прибуває
Флоріан Гаас зі своєю командою.
Дані дослідників льодовиків -
це своєрідний журнал змін клімату.
Ґепачфернер - це місце,
де можна побачити й почути
наслідки глобального потепління.
* Журчання води *
Це тала вода від льодовика.
У цьому районі
взимку більше немає снігу.
Тала вода на поверхні - це все,
що починає танути на льодовику
через високі температури останніх днів,
сонячне випромінювання і темний бруд.
Куди око гляне - все капає, тече і дзюркотить.
Це візит на смертне ложе льодовиків.
Дані географів описують зміни та небезпеки.
Після безсніжної зими й такого теплого літа
льодовик зменшився особливо сильно.
Там, де тануть льодовики,
ландшафт починає рухатись.
Є небезпека, що схили поваляться вниз
і принесуть у долину зсуви.
Наші скани фіксують деякі екстремальні випадки:
інтенсивні каменепади, під час яких
частково цілий схил може перебувати в русі,
тобто може відбутися обвал.
Це один з наслідків
інтенсивного танення льодовика.
Ґепачфернер щороку втрачає
понад 100 метрів свого розміру.
Через глобальне танення льодовиків
рівень моря підвищується,
і клімат дедалі більше втрачає баланс.
Географи збирають для своїх досліджень
фотографії, зроблені людьми в різні часи,
починаючи аж з XIX ст.
Вони демонструють, як кліматичні зміни
роз'їдають увесь ландшафт.
Я часто показую фотографії
своєму восьмирічному синові
і шестирічній доньці.
І я маю сумніви,
що вони встигнуть побачити стільки льодовиків.
Поруч із льодовиком справді вражає
швидкістю його танення.
До 90-х років темп був досить стабільним,
але відтоді стрімко зріс.
Там, де сьогодні ходять дослідники,
до 2050 року зовсім не залишиться льоду.
Навіть за найефективніших заходів із захисту клімату,
льодовик танутиме протягом наступних трьох десятиліть.
Разом з льодовиками тане і міф про вічні льоди.
Гора кличе по допомогу.
І приваблює відчайдушних та завзятих любителів гір.
Можливо, саме це захоплення людей
екстремальними висотами та пристрасть
до підкорення альпійських вершин
спонукає всіх нас схаменутися
та врятувати те, що вже на межі зникнення.
Цього літа ZDF запрошує вас поринути разом з нами
у гірські світи.
У четвер о 22:15 ми вирушимо з вами до Альп.
Це варте перегляду.
Відео ви можете переглянути вже зараз на сайті ZDF.
А зараз Ханна розповість невтішні новини
про розклад рейсів.
Авіакомпанія Lufthansa відповіла
на попереджувальний страйк наземного персоналу
різкими скасуваннями у розкладі рейсів.
Завтра перевізник анулює понад 1000 польотів
у своїх хабах у Франкфурті та Мюнхені.
За словами авіакомпанії, наслідки можуть
бути відчутними трохи довше.
Про це - Франк Бетман.
Це дійсно так, у четвер чи у п'ятницю
також можливе скасування рейсів.
Сьогодні компанія Lufthansa заявила,
що ситуація має стабілізуватися на вихідних.
Звичайно, це також пов'язано з початком
сезону літніх відпусток
в Баварії та Баден-Вюртемберзі.
У франкфуртському аеропорту
вже сьогодні скасували деякі рейси.
Загалом сьогодні та завтра
не відбудуться 678 рейсів.
Авіакомпанія попереджає, що постраждають
92 тис. пасажирів,
які не зможуть потрапити в аеропорт
без перебронювання квитків.
Насамперед це стосуватиметься тих пасажирів,
які мали прибути з далеких пунктів призначення
завтра вранці в аеропорти Німеччини.
Як-от рейси з Бангкока, Сеула чи Нью-Йорка.
Як попередньо оголосила Lufthansa,
ці літаки ще не вилетіли.
Та це не єдина проблема, яка постала
перед авіакомпанією.
Так, пілоти також оголосили про можливий страйк.
Голосування щодо проведення страйку
має відбутися в неділю.
Якщо ж більшість погодиться, регулярність польотів
буде під дедалі більшою загрозою.
Тож перспективи не дуже втішні
ні для клієнтів, ні, власне, для Lufthansa.
Найбільша авіакомпанія Німеччини
підриває свою надійність,
створивши власноруч забагато проблем.
Навіть на фондовій біржі Lufthansa
втрачає свої позиції.
Акції показують низхідний тренд
впродовж багатьох років.
На зв'язку був Франк Бетман з Франкфурта.
Щиро дякую.
Міжнародний валютний фонд укотре знизив
свій прогноз зростання світової економіки на цей рік.
Через російсько-українську війну та зростання інфляції
відсоток економічного зростання становитиме 3,2%,
що на 0,4 відсоткового пункта
нижче квітневого прогнозу.
МВФ також очікує, що в Єврозоні відсоток
зростання становитиме 2,6%,
що на 0,2 відсоткового пункта менше, ніж раніше.
Завтра збірна Німеччини зіграє зі збірною Франції
у півфіналі Чемпіонату Європи з футболу серед жінок.
Переглянути футбол Ви можете
завтра на каналі ZDF о 20:15.
І сьогодні вже зрозуміло:
якщо жіноча збірна Німеччини переможе,
у фіналі вона зустрінеться зі збірною Англії.
Сльози щастя.
Вони не можуть у це повірити.
Гра вдома завжди означає величезний тиск.
Тепер мрія про вихід у фінал справджується
після незабутньої гри, справжнього футбольного свята
з видовищними голами.
У першому таймі рахунок був 1:0
на користь Англії,
але після зміни сторін поля їх вже не зупинити.
Люсі Бронз змінює рахунокна 2:0, а згодом -
дивовижний третій гол АлесіїРуссо.
Сьогодні ввечері господиням матчу вдається все.
Для збірної Швеції результати зовсім невтішні:
матч завершився з рахунком 4:0 на користь Англії.
Зіграти зі збірною Німеччини у фіналі було б непогано.
Його вважають корифеєм клезмерської музики.
Гіора Фейдман сьогодні дав концерт у Берліні
на честь 75-річчя своєї музичної діяльності,
а також подарував один зі своїх кларнетів
Єврейському музею,
де його зберігатимуть як експонат.
86-річний музикант має єврейське походження
і давно виступає за німецько-єврейське примирення.
Ми розпочали сьогоднішній випуск
з обговорення Росії:
з нової холодної війни в космосі,
з побоювань щодо нестачі газу
та закликів до економії енергії.
А завершимо ми цей випуск обговоренням того,
як Москва обговорює нас.
Це офіційна позиція, яку суворо контролює влада.
Це єдина позиція, до якої дослухається
більшість населення в Росії.
Докладніше - Фібі Гаа.
«60 минут» - назва програми, яку веде Ольга Скабєєва.
Відтоді як російські солдати
почали воювати проти України,
програма триває вдвічі довше
і виходить в ефір двічі на день.
Зараз одна з головних тем програми:
Німеччина переймається
проблемами енергетичної безпеки.
Абсолютно страшно.
Ця картинка закликає мити
лише чотири частини тіла,
щоб роздратувати президента.
Це сенсація.
Навіть Путін прокоментував комічну картинку,
яку поширювали здебільшого
на проросійських каналах соціальних мереж.
Хочеш розізлити Путіна, мий лише ці чотири місця.
Що це таке?
Зовсім з розуму зійшли?
Економте воду, економте енергію, економте
електроенергію - якась нісенітниця.
Наробили помилок,
а тепер не знають, що з цим робити.
Державні канали повідомляють,
що без російського газу
Німеччині загрожує холодна зима.
А в інтернеті поширюють жарти.
«Що станеться, коли Європі відключать газ?»
«Чи вистачає тобі американського газу, Німеччино?»
«Дякую, але ні», - співають у відповідь.
Олександр Мінкін каже, що пропаганда працює.
У березні журналіст звільнився
з газети «Московский комсомолец»,
тому що він більше не міг
терпіти те, що там публікували.
Якби в Росії з'явилася вільна преса,
тоді б державна система брехні почала б розпадатися,
завалюватися, як підірваний будинок.
Посилення ізоляції, зростання
цін на продовольчі товари -
у росіян є підстави для хвилювання.
Пропаганда відволікає від цього.
Вона змушує повірити в те,
що доля інших - тих, хто
живе на Заході, - набагато важча.
Не можна вимикати газ, вони теж люди.
Буде холодно, вони замерзнуть.
Вони самі себе задавлять.
Нам не потрібно робити нічого особливого.
Ви ж бачите, що всі їхні проблеми
спричинені лише їхніми вчинками.
Це майже дослівно неодноразово повторювали
в ефірах державних каналів.
Тут наговорюють, загрожують
і завжди наголошують на власній силі.
Шольце, ти зрозумій: ніякої поразки Росії не буде.
Поразка Росії - знищення всього світу.
Це світ думок,
який щодня миготить на екранах телевізорів у Росії
і вже давно впливає на суспільство.
В Індексі свободи преси, який укладає
організація «Репортери без кордонів»,
Росія посідає 155-е місце,
між Азербайджаном та Афганістаном.
«Що буде з нашими мріями?» -
про це йтиметься одразу після нашого випуску
у репортажі «37 Grad».
Дві сім'ї, які були змушені евакуюватися з України
та опинилися в селі в районі Обербергішер,
стикаються із запитанням, як жити далі.
Вже незабаром на каналі ZDF.
І ми знову побачимося з вами завтра.
Гарного вечора. До побачення.
Добрий вечір. Ласкаво просимо до перегляду
прогнозу погоди.
У деяких частинах Європи панує посуха,
вона триватиме і далі.
Знову розширюється область антициклону,
який сягне і Німеччини.
Відходить циклон,
а з північного заходу надходить холодне повітря.
Це робить погоду більш стерпною.
Вночі йтиме невеликий дощ,
але він поступово стихне,
і знов буде сухо, як і в інших регіонах.
Найнижча температура на півночі - 9-13°С,
у північній частині країни набагато холодніше,
ніж у південній.
Можна відчути, що надходять маси
холодного повітря.
Але на південному заході у напрямку регіону Рейн-Майн
очікується помірна температура - 16°С.
Завтра впродовж дня очікується сильний вітер
з північно-західних напрямків,
подекуди можливий буревій.
На півночі буде дещо хмарніше,
ніж на південному заході.
Лише на південному сході у напрямку Баварії
у гірських регіонах очікуються зливи та грози.
Але дощ йтиме лише подекуди.
Найвища температура на півдні - 25-27°С.
Набагато прохолодніше на півночі
та у напрямку Північнонімецької низовини - 17-20°С.
У четвер на півдні знову очікуються грози,
в інших регіонах -
сухо, 19-31°С.
У п'ятницю частіше йтимуть зливи та грози,
але знову лише подекуди.
Гарного вечора!